I went to the Student Union I knew the
kid there who was in charge I said I'm
going to do this I said I'm not going to
borrow a dime until like we have a show
it was a massive hit it was the same so
you're the king of Chapel Hill
the guy who wrote for the paper in
Raleigh
ended really what was my career by
letting everyone know you were Jewish
I'm like this is all well and good but
he's kind of Distributing dangerous
ideas to the Christian Youth here in
North Carolina the first girl I went out
with there yeah at Chapel Hill said
literally within four minutes he
you know I've never dated a Jewish man
before
and I was like rubbish
did she ask you to do that she had a
thing she was like do one of the most
Jewish gestures possible rub your hands
together
she didn't touch my head to see if I had
horns